here we are on the set of the changeling
this is Victor Laval the author of The
Changeling and this is Kelly Marcel the
showrunner and creator of the changeling
show Welcome to the elk Hotel this is
the hotel of one of our episodes yes
it's about a character named Lillian
Apollo's mother as she goes through her
own night it's like a dark night of the
Soul we'd love to show you around the
lobby and the hotel in our show we have
Easter eggs here's one this sign is
signed by management Lester Lester Cohen
is the production designer and he is The
Mastermind behind this amazing set yes
and if we come over here we will see
another wonderful Easter egg which is
this ship which is called a Sloop you've
read the book and are a fan of the book
then you already know how important this
will be one other detail that we've been
talking about today is how much we love
the wallpaper in this Lobby and actually
as we go through the hotel you're going
to see that Leicester has chosen very
solid colors for reach section because
it's a very dreamlike episode
well why don't you let us show you the
rest of the hotel yeah the other thing
that's interesting about the elk hotel
is this whole episode is not in the book
this is something that came about from
Kelly and I talking so it's not in the
book but really slides nicely into the
world of our show but this hotel really
existed this is actually the color that
the walls were
very nightmarish
this is patient Zero's room so Lester's
removed the two and the zero when you
watch the episode this room will
completely transform
[Music]
this episode is about people who have
found themselves feeling discarded or
forgotten and all of them sort of help
each other through the experience
Lillian goes through this episode she
starts to remember places and people
from her life
and we get to see her memories like this
this is one of Lillian's memories
not one of the great memories no
you will see some graffiti and this
tabletop will magically change by the
end of this episode and feature carvings
that you've seen on the first page of
Victor's book
tell me your life's voyage
tell you
Who You Are